الطائره تحمل طريقا من يعني
المسعفين وطرق البحث والانقاذ البريطانيه
العمل معهم ادويه امن معهم خلافا مدربه
للمساعده في عمليات البحث هذا الفريق
البريطاني الان ينتظر الانتهاء من اجراءات
دخوله الى تركيا اليوم ايضا وصلت الى
تركيا او الى مطار غازي عنتاب اربع طائرات
قطريه في اطار جسر جوي دشنته الحكومه
القطريه من اجل تقديم المساعدات لتركيا في
هذه الازمه التي تعيشها ويعني
بالاضافه الى هذه الاربع طائرات حملت 140
من عناصر الفرق لانقاذ والبحث مسعفين
واطباء والمستلزمات الكافيه لبناء
مستشفيين ميدانيين حتى الان لا نعرف لا
نعلم اين سوف يتم بناؤها لكن التجهيزات
الضروريه لبناء الميدانيين قد وصلت وهذا
الفرق القطريه سوف تلتحق باداره الكوارث
والطوارئ التركيه التي سوف تحدد ما هي
الاماكن التي توجد فيها حاجه لمثل هذه
الخدمات هذا المطر الذي
ليس يعني في حركيه نشيطه لايصال المساعدات
واصول القوافل
والدعم الذي تقدمه عدد من الدول وصل
الطائره من اسرائيل وصل دائره من ايران
طائره من تركمانستان هناك دول كثيره يتم
ايصال المساعدات عبر مطار غازي عنتاب
بالنظر الى انه المطار الذي لم يتضرر
كثيرا مقارنه مع مطارات اخرى في
تركيا لكن المطار ايضا هو ماوى وملجا
لعديد من سكان ولايه غازي عنتاب الذين
يعني شعروا بالقلق خلال اليومين الماضيين
بعد كثره الزلازلات الارتداديه
يعني على الاقل في هذه القاعه يتواجد
هؤلاء الذين يروا يعني يجدون فيها مكان
دافئ مكان يتم توفير فيه الغذاء وبالتالي
يعني اطفال يجدون الامان او الحد الادنى
من الامان لكي يعني يهناؤ بساعات قليله من
النوم مقارنه مع اخرين يتواجدون في شوارع
والساحات العموميه في مدينه غازي عنتاب
الذين يخشون حتى الان من العوده الى
منازلهم